be scared of death I mean I'm scared of
death you know because I I like I like
living I kind of I kind of enjoy it you
know I accept mortality
you know like I hate to break it to you
but
this isn't this doesn't end well right
so if you can accept that that is the
case the question is how do you ensure
that your ideas will live on through
your work and through the people who've
been through your life that people will
say of you I am who I am today and I'm a
bitter version of myself because you
were my friend
right like are you do you live your life
that one day people would say that do
you build your business so that people
say I'm a better version of myself
because I worked at this company
you know I mean to me that's that that's
that's the path that I've chosen for
myself anyway